who am i
luigi asks his mother maria
luigi he reminds her it's all a little
overwhelming
with the mask is difficult in the
plastic barrier
she has difficulty recognizing who it is
but at least
she did recognize me after a few minutes
this is the first so-called hug bubble
in southern italy
plastic divides them and yet it's the
closest they've been able to get to each
other in almost a year
a simple touch once taken for granted is
now
everything in between family visits
everything gets sanitized a new reality
that's still hard to get used to
this structure gets moved around these
villagers to the homes
for the elderly there are four with
around 200
residents and this is so everyone gets a
chance to hold
and to feel and to somehow still
physically touch their loved ones
something that's been so terribly missed
during this pandemic
father and daughter kiss for only the
second time in a year
she tells him everything passes didn't
the war pause too
[Music]
these are emotional moments it's been a
long
lonely year for many italy has the
second highest elderly population in the
world
and one of the highest coronavirus death
tolls in europe at more than
80 000 so far it's also a culture of
large family gatherings
with grandparents often at the very
center
my dream is to hug all my relatives
again to have company
to see happiness for us all to be
together
vaccination campaign is underway with
the elderly due to be inoculated after
health workers
and those involved in this hug bubble
project in the villages outside of
naples
say it started just a few days before
christmas and believe it will have to
remain in place for a while longer
the vaccine isn't a magic potion and you
are not immediately immune
and so we will still have weeks probably
months ahead of us
in which we will need to maintain all of
these protective measures
and so this room will continue to be an
opportunity for relatives
to be able to get close to their loved
ones
touch even through plastic has become so
very precious these days
[Music]
i want to go home maria pleads with her
son
he tells her not to cry this pandemic
has made the pain of loneliness
even worse stephanie decker al jazeera
avelino in southern italy